je quitte mes vieilles pierres mes
vieilles habitudes mon vieux quartier
déal que j'aimais beaucoup et les larmes
ne sont pas loin mais ça c'est du
passé ce marché est magnifique c'est un
marché d'avenir qui sera certainement
[Musique]
sensationnel mardi 4 mars aux petites
heures de la matinée nous accompagnons
un restaurateur parisien monsieur Bajard
qui va pour la première fois à ringis
comment ça se présente monsieur Bajard
et bien écoutez monsieur dans l'état
actuel des choses c'est la grande
inconnue depuis plusieurs années que
nous entendons parler de ringis ça
devient une
réalisation et à mon sens il va falloir
une nouvelle adaptation à tout point de
vue qu'est-ce qui nous attend àis c'est
très difficile à dire bien que N nous
avons déjà fait des sondages j suis allé
déjà C fois pour bien repérer les
emplacements essayer de retrouver tous
mes fournisseur c'est à peu près chose
faite à l'heure actuelle donc dès lors
je sais où je
vais est-ce que ce n'est pas avec
amertume que vous avez quitté les Halles
de Paris il y a toujours une petite
pointe d'amertume quand on lance quand
on laisse quand même une choses comme
les H qui existent depuis si longtemps
où il y a un rit où il y a des des
choses qui sont bien établies est-ce que
vous avez assisté à la fin des Halles
j'ai assisté à la fin des hall en tant
que achat et vente mais ma dernière nuit
je ne l'ai pas pensé au
comme il faut que je me lève de très
bonne heure le
matin je n'ai donc pas assister à la à
la fête toute dernière
[Musique]
des
pour la dernière nuit restaurants et
cafés des vieilles HES avaient fait le
plein mais cette gé était un peu forcée
et à l'aube une grande lassitude
enveloppait ce bon vieux quartier c'est
avec une certaine amertume que le
dernier marché fini chacun commençait à
charger sa rerre et son matériel c'était
le déménagement du siècle en route pour
ris pour l'inconnu au revoir Paris Ton
cœur avait du mal à respirer on t'en
agffé un tout neuf immense moderne
fonctionnel il te faudra bientôt
alimenter 12 millions
[Musique]
destomac
alors voyez là nous
[Musique]
arayons je vais aller
tourner à l'entrée de ringis sur le côté
nord je crois et je vais revenir par la
marée pour aller au Pavillon A3
c'est-à-dire légumes et B3 légumes
également il y a pas encore le péage
pour l'instant pas pour le
moment mais certainement ça ne serurait
tardé l'organisation général du marché
de
ringis attend que l'on soit un peu rodé
avant de mettre le péage de faire payer
le parking également il en est fortement
question est-ce que ça fera des frais
supplémentaires pour vous de venir à
ringist il y aura les frais de parking
et puis les frais d'essence mais qui
malgré tout sont sont minimes
[Musique]
comme à Paris le premier marché à ouvrir
c'est celui des fruits et légumes à 3h
c'est tôt et l' parle déjà sérieusement
de le mettre l'après-midi au mois
d'octobre peut-être des pavillons comme
celui-là il y en a 9 de près de 200 m de
long 60 m de large et il y en a encore
qu autres plus
petits
al ici c'est le bâtiment des fruits et
légumes comment ça se présente écoutez
ici nous sommes au Pavillon
B3 là je retrouve à peu près tous mes
fournisseurs habitué des Halles et d'
d'après ma première constatation tout à
l'air de marcher normalement
l'approvisionnement est
bon
et il reste plus qu'une question de mise
au point et d'organisation
finale ici rien à voir avec lesal de
Baltar chaque négociant dispose d'un
carreau à trois échelons les dépôts en
sous-sol reliés par monte charge au
carreau et à l'étage un bureau du vrai
moderne tout
cela nous recevons les marchandises par
ici sur les quê des groupage nous les
rentrons en magasin sur palette n'est-ce
pas et ensuite nous remplissons les
aires d'étalage qui correspondent à à
montrer la marchand au client alors
ensuite le client fait son choix achète
nous passons sur bascule électronique
qui monte à l'ordinateur qui est au
bureau et 30 secondes après vous avez la
facturation complète qui redescend qui
redescend à la disposition des clients
est-ce que c'était déjà comme ça sur
votre carreau non pas du tout c'était
très périmé làbas c'était
déplassé alors ici vous avez le bureau
rort
avec tout ce que ça consiste c'estàd
interphone
téléphone téléphone telx ça change avec
la rue sainti étant donné que là-bas on
était vraiment dans un ti là est-ce que
pour le premier jour vous avez eu autant
de clients que vous l'espériez bah très
honnêtement on a eu davantage de monde
qu'on le pensait on était un peu inquiet
quand même de la de l'ouverture de ce
marché d'intérêt national de rangis mais
comment dirais-je à l'heure actuelle on
a même je peux vous dire qu'on a eu des
clients d'un périphérique de 150 à 200
km des gens d'Orléan j'ai vu même des
gens de tour qui sont venus nous voir
qui nous ont pas acheté mais qui sont
venus comme curieux est sûrement
intéressé par la suite les gens qui
n'allaient pas oùavant à cause d'un
problème de stationnement qui viennent à
ring et qui sûement viendront à
[Musique]
ring bon dis
donc alors bon combien tu vas me faire
ça vaut
18 à
14 14 14 toujours
dur
faire ça inaugurer le pavillon des
fleurs pour commencer
combien 4
voilà quelques détails à régler encore
celui de la manutention surtout
normalement chaque acheteur doit
disposer d'un emplacement au
embarquement des manutentionnaires sont
mis à sa disposition par les grossistes
mais il faut que cela
s'organise quelles sont vos impressions
premier jour
bah pour commencer ça paraît un peu on
est un peu perdu quoi mais
on va certainement pouvoir faire de
meilleurs achats que on était trop bien
làbas V est beau monieur lui causait pas
il a un caract infernal pu fait trop
chaud là V suis employé monsê employé ou
et ben mon Dieu je vais essayer de tenir
ma mon temps de travail ici pour venir
travailler ici comment comment et Benon
on a pris un taxi ce matin mais j'espère
ne pas en prendre un tous les jours
monsieur parce que ça revient cher vous
savez Paris j'habite la rue de la
ferronnerie vous voyez que j'étais
heureuse d'être au Wall de Paris
puis que c'est comme ça j'ai bien mais
un taxi c'est trop cher tous les jours
vraiment j'ai
seré ma poulette j'esserai de ne pas le
prendre mais on vair des
transp depuis quelques instants la
première marée de ringis est commencé
normalement l'ouverture est à 6h mais il
semble qu'elle soit avancé à
5h
il n'y a qu'un hall de la marée très
vaste l'un des plus grands du marché
d'intérêt national de ringis avec celui
des fleurs et c'est la seconde halte de
Monsieur Bajard le restaurateur que nous
suivons dans ses
achats
je retrouve un de mes fournisseurs
habituel Monsieur Le Fèvre et là je trie
mes sols pour avoir des sols autant que
possible de la même
dimension il y a une chose qui n'est qui
choque un peu c'est la lumière vis-à-vis
du poisson il y a un éclairage au néon
qui est très désagréable parce que on a
l'impression que le poisson
est légèrement tourné
pour vous poissonnier quelle est la
différence une très grosse différence il
faut
s'adapter pour moi personnellement
j'habite très près alors j'ai pas un
problème j'ai pas j'ai pas un problème
de transport mais j'ai des collègues qui
ont un problème de transport ensuite il
y a la lumière bien sûr ça cette lumière
on pense que ça va on remédier pu enfin
il faut s'y faire il faut il faut une
adaptation une
adaptation progressive ça sera long je
crois que pour l'instant tout le monde
est un peu perdu il faut attendre mois
avant de savoir si oui ou non il est
rentable de continuer pour nous à venir
au Hal je suis pas tellement sûr que ce
soit bon comment ferez-vous autrement
bien nous seront obligés de passer par
des grossistes et par conséquent d'avoir
des pris supérieures mais je ne crois
pas que nous puissions ou alors il va
falloir coucher là parce qu'il y a 4 km
je crois entre entre les légumes et la
et les poissons ou alors il va ître une
nouvelle génération de restaurateurs à
gros mollet
énorme 7h au marché des bof les beurs F
fromage les ventes vont commencer mais
déjà et se vide beaucoup craignent les
embouteillages ce sera d'ailleurs le
moment le plus difficile sur l'autoroute
du Sud mais pour venir tout s'était bien
passé prier cou je que c'est du sport et
pour arriver ici jusqu'ici
ciable c'est impeccable vous pensez que
ça sera mieux quand même ah oui ah oui i
je crois que quand même plus agréable
plus
grand prier temps ça dur et l'ambiance
des HES là-bas vous regrettez pas
oh avec le jour l'animation s'est
déplacée elle est maintenant au sud-est
près des rues de charant d'auverne de
franchecté dans les quatre pavillons des
produits laitiers et des
œufs pas est-ce que vous êtes content
d'êreiste bien la vérité c'est que j'ai
d'abord au point de vue sentimental les
larmes au bord des yeux parce que je
quitte mes vieilles pierres mes vieilles
habitudes mon vieux quartieridal que
j'aimais beaucoup et les larmes ne sont
pas loin mais ça c'est du passé ce
marché est magnifique c'est un marché
d'avenir qui sera certainement
sensationnel la grosse erreur pour moi
c'est qu'on l'a ouvert un mois trop
tôt et au moment propice vous
en
vous avez fini vos achats là et bien
voilà c'est terminé oui première journée
de ringice et dans le fond je suis pas
mécontent on a patogé un peu pour le
poisson parce qu'il a fallu retrouver un
petit peu les postes mais les légumes
j'étais au courant ça s'est bien passé
le poisson malgré tout aussi le fromage
également et maintenant reste le retour
sur Paris alors là ça va être
certainement autre chose voilà le point
crucial est-ce que vous aurez mis en
tout plus de temps que d'habitude plus
absolument pas plus et je crois que une
fois que tout va être ré on va même
gagner du temps sur
les pas encore de soupe à l'Ignon pas
encore de soupe àignon mais très
certainement la semaine
prochaine la
marmite à partir de lundi
soir et bien non finalement ce n'est pas
alpaville c'est r une ville toute neuve
qui demande à vivre déjà les habitudes
s'installent les ordinateurs les Mones
charg les telx tout cela n'étonne pas
cette page d'histoire aur aussi bien pu
se tourner il y a 10
[Musique]
ans